RETO MEIER: Today we're
talking about Pub/Sub
in Cloud Monitoring and an
AI-searchable Video Archive.
I'm Reto Meier, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
Cloud Monitoring
is a service that
can alert you through a variety
of notification channels, which
now includes Cloud Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is a
publish/subscribe queue
that lets you build loosely
coupled applications.
With this integration,
currently in beta,
you can create automated
and programmatic workflows
in response to alerts.
For example, by integrating
with third party providers
to create an incident
response workflow.
We've just published the first
episode of Google Cloud Drawing
Board, a new video series that
breaks down various Google
Cloud tools and shows you how
they work and what they can do.
In the first video,
Priyanka Vergadia
covers Compute Engine,
showing off various use cases
and how you can use
it for your projects
while managing your costs.
Last week, Dale
Markowitz shared a post
explaining how she used Google
Cloud to build an AI-searchable
Video Archive as a
Father's Day gift.
She took over 456 hours
of digitized footage
in Google Drive and
created a way for her dad
to rediscover forgotten moments.
And then she turned around
and showed us how she did it.
It's a pretty fantastic
read, and it demonstrates
that while building a searchable
index for video archive
is fun for personal
projects, it's
also useful for
businesses looking
to automatically generate
metadata for large video data
sets, caption and translate
clips, or quickly search
brand and creative assets.
We're only three weeks away
from Google Cloud Next.
For 2020, we've reimagined
this annual conference
into a 9-week digital event.
There's a lot to explore, so
we've created session packages
to help attendees discover
and explore sessions
that they're interested in.
Check these out for
yourself, and be
sure to add a package
to your playlist
so that you don't miss a thing.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see the full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.